In August of two thousand and one. Me and my boyfriend of
six years. My first love of my life went through one of the
worst break-ups in the history of recorded man. And I know that may sound naive
or
self-absorbed. And that's because it is. But I swear it was really
really bad. We worked together at the same company. But
that's not where we met. We'd met in college when we were both like eighteen, nineteen years
old and when we met I was this like, super super
nerdy virgin.
I know it's hard to imagine but I was really a nerd I was really a virgin.
And he was sort of this chubby, like, almost virgin. You know what I mean? Like
he had a
really fat face and, uhm, and he had slept with someone, but it was like
really should have been, was like he maybe stuck it into someone like an inch.
You know what I mean? But, for all intents and purposes, anyway.
So we both had really low self-esteem. And that was sort of part of what brought us together, you
know, it's like "I feel crappy about myself.""So do I! Do want to come over and have sex?"
So that was like a part of the thing, but then the magical thing that happened was
was we got in this relationship. We loved each other and we showered each other with affection and sex and love. And over time
we started to feel better about ourselves, you know, so like at the end of the six years we
were
both feeling OK and we were both sort of
secretly independently wondering what it would be like, to sort of like, give having
sex with someone else a go. You know what I mean? And that's where the relationship began to
crumble and even though we still loved each other, we ended up breaking up and he asked me to
move out of our shared house.
And I was devastated. But it was the sort of devastated where
you think you feel bad but something's going to happen that's going to make you feel worse.
And for me that was finding out that
like three weeks after I moved out, he started sleeping with his
twenty-two year old blonde assistant at the same company we worked at. She sat like five
feet away from me.
Yeah. What a fucker, right? She...
I was... I am a normally level-headed human being. I went fucking ape-shit.
I went berserker. I didn't know how to handle this. It was the worst thing that had ever
happened to me in my life.
Like, it was a month, ?parr with? six years is the worst thing. And the w- w-
what made it even worse, is, she was absolutely like a Jewish's girls, like,
like worst
shiksa nightmare. Do you know what I mean? She was ,like, blonde, she was petite, she
was waify, she had a pert nose and, like, no visible body hair. It was just, like, the worst thing. So as a jew
I hated her for being everything that
I wasn't. But then the worst fucking thing was that someone who was in the know
told me that she was also a Jew.
I was like, oh my God! I was like how could like a member of
my own tribe betray me this way?! And the worst thing was that now
there was like the potential for her to actually be, like, neurotic and interesting. You know what
I mean? And I couldn't just imagine her as this sort of like
emotionless WASP. You know, which is what I'd been thinking to make myself feel better. And I know
that it's like wrong to ethnically
stereotype people. But I feel like if you already hate them for really valid reasons already,
it's OK. It's alright. Right? So I just, I, I
was having a break- a BREAKdown. Just a total
breakdown. But I was like, OK I'm a normal human being. I will take
the route people can take to recover from this in the normal amount of time. So I tried going to
therapy to talk it out. Didn't work. I tried going to the gym to work it out-
that didn't work. Instead I fell into this depressive
fucking spiral where I couldn't think about anything. I was just ruled by
these two horrible urges. One was the urge to just sort of
masochistically think about how much prettier she was than me, and everything about her that was
- I don't know, just so much more perfect and sexier and better.
The other urge was that I needed to find out anything- something about her- something about her
personality that would allow me to hate her. That would allow me to feel superior to her like some, like, bit
of dirt on her that would prove she was actually... shitty.
That wasn't what I had planned to say, but it's really what was here, ha, um. So one day,
I'm whining on the phone to my friend, Wendy. God bless Wendy. And I'm like "Hey,
[mumble mumble]. And uh, I wanted to
hate her. "I wanna hate her, what can I find out to make her hate-able?" And she was like "Well, have you
tried Googling her?" Now,
I was a nerd but I was not a geek. So I didn't know what Google was.
I didn't know and I'm sure- right, you all know what it is?
If there's one or two people here I'll explain it. Google is the most powerful thing ever
invented on the planet.
It is this fucking insane search engine that allows you to be crazy
and stalk someone from the comfort of your own fucking home. Right?
It is a more important invention than fire or the wheel, as
far as I'm concerned. So she was like "Why don't you google her?"And I was like, "Shyeahh"
I'm going to google the crap out of
this girl. 'Cause I knew her
name!  So I went to the little search window and I entered her name. I
won't say her name here but needless to say, it was Slutskank.
So I google her, and I didn't understand the power of Google so I wasn't
really expecting anything to happen. But within three seconds, this link comes up and it takes me to
this , um, article that had been an interview with her from her college
newspaper freshman
year. And it was, like, this thing where she was like the "campus celebrity of the day." And I
was like- that's retarded. Um, so hopefully that would prove that she
too was retarded. But that's not what fucking happened. Listen to this.
So, um, the thing comes up. There's a photo of her. And it's
the most adorable photo of a human-being ever taken. She couldn't look blonder or
more ?WASPy? Jewish. She's, like, wearing low-rider sweat pants before anyone
even knew about those. And like a thing with a cow on it and she's just in the three corners
great- UHH! And that drove me nuts. And I was scared to move on to the article
but I did. It was an interview and in the interview she revealed that her
greatest desire/ goal in life was to become a stand-up comic. A famous stand-up
comic. I was like, fuck me.
Because that's- that was MY secret goal. That was MY goal.
And I'd always wanted to do
that since I was a kid but I'd never had the guts, I'd never had the ?moxie? to do it. And here it was, I was reading
she was already in a sketch group, oh my God, I was like, so OK
she's... she LOOKS
?WASPy? but she's
Jewish. She's banging my boyfriend. And she's already like apparently on her way to like
achieving MY dream. This cannot stand. Um, and I
decided
if we were both like aiming for the moon, right, and both had the same goal- this is going to be a
fucking space-race, right? And if it kills me, I'm going to be John Fucking Glenn.
I'm getting there first, right. So I start to
perform. The ironic thing, I've never been more miserable in my life. And I start trying to write jokes and
go perform. I'm going to open mic's and its depressing. And I hate it. But over time it's like
slowly improving. I get to do book-shows. ?So I go to? like two or three depressing open mic's,
or four or five, like, OK shows a
week. But all along, I'm still just like manically depressed
right. And I'm like Googling her endlessly. And looking at the picture and that
picture became the focal point not only of my loathing for her but my loathing for myself
and I literally, like five or six times a day, would just stare at the photo. I felt terrible about myself and
my therapist was like "If you don't stop Googling her, I'm going to call
your doctor and put you on Prozac." And I didn't want to go on Prozac because I was scared that one
side effects of Prozac would be that I would become less witty. And being witty was sort of the only
side effect of being depressed that was working for me. You know what I
mean? So, haha,
you really should not clap, but so I was like "FUCK" so I decided to
keep performing and I'm not going to go on Prozac. Yet.
So I'm performing. So one day I'm doing this show- it's like at a slightly better place than I usually do it- and I'm watching
the audience stream in to you know, filling in before the show starts and who walks in but HER
She comes in- the show had been advertised in ?Time Out New York?, my name, it was very clear.
She must've known I was going to be there. I was, like,
what's fucking kind of weird drive-by shit is this? 'Cause she
sat in the FRONT fucking row and it was clear
and I was like oh my God I
felt so terrible, I was looking at her, and she was pretty, and- and-
I barely could go on and it just so upset me. l managed to do it and I ran out as soon as I was done. I ran home 'cause I needed
to have my nightly loathe-fest with the photo, right, and I'm sitting. I was just, like, how could she do it?
I'm about to google her and all of a sudden it occurs to me- maybe the reason she came there is because she's also
obsessed with me, like,
I am the girl before! She's dating this guy I was with for six years so she must be
curious- it must be driving her crazy! And I was like *Gasp* "What if she's Googling ME?'
And I don't know
why it had never occurred to me to try Googling myself- I think that there was a rule against it or
something, or that the computer would, like, implode. Like- like- the
self-absorption wouldn't be handled. But I was like, I'm going to do it. I type my
name in- I
Google MYSELF. And to my shock and amazement, there's like shit there
on the computer- about me! I didn't put it
there. And it's all stuff about performing. It's all like links to advertising for shows I had
I had done- stuff that was like still there. One or two like kind of just really brief like nice
mentions about things in it. Like just sort of briefly made me feel better because it was like, OK
if this is the space-race, maybe fucking little Sputnik-bitch is not like as far ahead of me as
I thought. But whatever, OK, so just like take a breath.
And it- but it did- It made me feel better and like, I realized it was the only antidote
,to like the shitty feelings I had when I would Google her, was to Google myself. And that's how I became obsessed with
Googling myself
And here's the thing about Googling yourself- it's as dirty as it sounds. You know what I mean?
It IS masturb- it just IS masturbating. There's no- like, you have this
urge to do it but you don't want anyone to know you're doing it. But the thing is, just like masturbating,
people deny it but everyone does it. You know what I mean? But I would Google myself, I would look
at things, I would see if anything new was coming up, blah blah blah. So
anyway... I couldn't stop. I was Googling her and googling myself. Googling her and Googling myself.
Feeling bad, feeling good. OK.
So, one day I do a show at ?Irving? Plaza. It was like this big thing.
Do the show. Next day. You know. Normal stuff. Come home, Google myself
Wanna check-in, wanna check-in
and umm.
Something new pops up and it's this thing, the heading, it's this link, it says "Funny Girl", I am like "What's this?"
and, um, I click on it and it takes me to craigslist
list.
Yes? Do we know what Craigslist is? If anyone here doesn't  know
It's like this hippie dippie bulletin board. People renting apartments and giving each other bikes and shit
and, um, But there's this thing on a called
Missed Connections. And that's a Funny Girl it's from and Missed Connections it's like that. You know
you know, on the back of the voice like when people see each on the street you're running down the street and you see someone cute or whatever.
And you don't have the guts to talk to them and then the next day you write something that's like, "hey I saw you on six avenue and
eight street. You're wearing a Metallica T-shirt... I like Metallica...ah, PLEASE CALL ME
You know. Like that! Billions of them! and that was "Funny Girl" was
was
someone wrote to me other imposers like funny girl like hey Jessie Klein.
I saw you at the show and I thought you're really
adorable. I want to talk to you afterwards but didn't have the guts, you can email me
can email me. This is the most amazing thing that had ever happened to me in my entire life
life. I've never had someone just sort of like me without putting the work into it like
when I used to want to hook up with guys. I had it was like a huge exertion of personality
which was exhausting it's exhausting have a personality.
Fuck me so OK. So
no. So OK so I was like oh my god thats amazing.
So, damn you and your violin.
Hers
is OK So that was like incredible thing. And I
was overjoyed to talked to my friend Nick about that Iwas like should I email this guy? and he's "like Jesse he looked at
the dates like that puts of the day if you did that show you the joke about he liked book I'd balls in your mouth
and I like what your point. What is your point. He likes me he
really likes me. Anyway it's clear it's like a couple days to think about it
right in the space of those you days. I continued to give myself more shit
more to start popping up on Craigslist.
About me. The second thing was from a totally different guy and it's like I saw
performing but this was kind of creepy it wasn't a brief and adorable it's like
little. And that's a real but yeah maybe the people on Craigslist the section on not dating material.
But it could sort of be funny material for the stage because it's really the greatest website ever.
So I started doing this bit all around town about
Craigslist and missed connections and I found that when I did it by saying it.
I was like inviting every like delinquent loon.
To my little out that they would people would yield to to me.
And stuff kept popping up popping up what I didn't immediately know. Was that a lot of it was from my
fuckin friends because once I told him at the first two they're like Ha ha would it be funny like. Baker out.
Those like the decoys but I don't care. But if you looked on craigslist it look like I was hot
shit like a week and like
autumn. I was the truck shit. I'm almost sixty don't play again.
So. You're very good.
But one day.
I come it's like within the place special. To eat. I get back to my office from lunch. And I have a
voicemail on my phone from a man who identified himself as a
writer for the fucking New Yorker. And he says hello. He's like I've you know
this stuff about you on
Craigslist. I would like to write a talk of the town
piece about you and like this crazy trend.
Please call me
a lot.
What better a binge on ex-boyfriend and on the left gang. Than
for them to read an article in The New Yorker about the fact that I am hot. And I'm funny.
And I have fucking groupies.
MY GOD OH MY FUCKING GOD and I was like I did. I call
of it
with don't feel it's like. I made it to the
moon first time to put the still down there bear with no one
writing about how you in the new word about what you're going to publication ever write. I've
never been this. I have no business. If I'm on the moon.
But then something happened which is that the article didn't happen.
Oh
I should love. Pity. No it didn't happen to disagree.
I don't even
remember why it didn't happen. I'm really three
Michigan. I don't know why it didn't happen. He was very nice and funny
comic put into its editor for some reason he couldn't get its through. I was really no. Eyes on the phone back
like it's OK don't worry OK fine hang up. But more disappointed
than ever been in my
life. And I started bawling bawling. Having a breakdown.
Bawling climbing. And during that ball. The house. I had
this like a piss knew where I left my body. Like my Tolson is like a can't take it I
left my body of floated up to the top of the often I look down and let's take a little land here.
I'm in my office. Right not done any work for my employer in about six months.
Lebed Dilling myself on the internet constantly. And I'm crying I'm crying and
I'm disappointed but
why not because I didn't get the article in The New Yorker. But because
the ex-boyfriend and the bank wouldn't read
it. That's fucked up. Write him. And
it was like at that second. It all just
are like dawned on me that in the years since the breakup I've become so obsessed with
being this race. To make other people laugh. That I lost my ability to laugh at
myself as like if I could just Wrekin you ability to step back and look at
all the crazy thing is I've been doing since the thing happened.
I would be a better comic. Like to be material that's much funnier than anything I've
been trying to write and moreover I would be a happier person.
So that's what I did and I've become a better comic. And I've become a
happier person. And the other thing I decided was I really need to try to get laid.
I'm desperate. And I try to do that
and after year kind of work and I've been dating
this guy that I really like and. I don't look at that girl's picture anymore.
But he and I google each other constantly. Thank you very
much Lou.